bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france est-ce que vous vous
attendiez à une telle situation comment
est-ce que vous l'expliquer ce matin
écoutez nous on ne s'attendait pas on
savait qu'il y avait des tensions on
savait que la situation était très
compliquée pour madame anne sotchi mais
néanmoins on n'imaginait pas que les
militaires pourraient avoir l'audace pas
ce qu'il s'est véritablement de l'audace
pour ne pas dire du culot de revenir sur
le devant de la scène
d'une part parce qu'ils ne sont pas
aimés et qu'ils sont craints en birmanie
d'autre part parce que le résultat des
élections législatives a été sans appel
ils ont perdu un grand nombre de sièges
et contrôle moins de 10% des sièges
élu à l'assemblée nationale et enfin
parce que la victoire d'hansson sushi
paraissait éclatante
lorsque les militaires évoquent donc un
contexte de fraudes électorales qui
auraient entâché ce scrutin législatives
de novembre dernier
c'est donc un faux prétexte à vos yeux c
est clairement un faux prétexte de la
commission électorale d'ailleurs à
refuser un recomptage des bulletins en
disant que les choses s'étaient passées
dans un dans une atmosphère apaisée et
constructive
il est clair quand on connaît la
birmanie et les méandres birman que la
géographie n'aide pas à la tenue d'un
scrutin
facile on est dans des régions parfois
montagneuse qu on atteint difficilement
en outre la crise sanitaire avait rendu
les choses encore plus difficiles mais
néanmoins avec plus de 82 % des sièges
on ne peut pas dire qu'il y ait eu
trucage ou que la lnd et volé cette
élection alors on l'a vu dans le sujet
précédent les relations ont toujours été
très compliquées en train de
gouvernement et les militaires
aujourd'hui les militaires ont tout
simplement voulu reprendre le pouvoir
selon vous écoutez je crois je crois
qu'en fait avec la constitution de 2008
les militaires ont d'abord ou voulu
conserver les rênes du pouvoir c'est à
dire donner éventuellement la façade du
pouvoir à la une
éventuelle opposition mais conserver le
coeur du pouvoir
or depuis qu'elle est arrivée au
gouvernement en 2000 début 2016
madame aung san suu kyi a finalement pas
mal géré la situation et notamment en
s'octroyant le titre de conseillère
d'état
alors qu'elle ne pouvait pas prétendre
aux plus hautes fonctions de l'état
puisque son mari est un étranger et que
l'un des articles de la constitution
stipule clairement que ce n'est pas
possible dans cette configuration là et
donc si vous voulez le bras de fer entre
l'armée et madame anne so she had
commencé à ce moment là et ça a été si
vous voulez un long plébiscite qui sait
qui était déjà présent en dehors des
élections de 2015 mais qui s'est
consolidée depuis 2015 pour arriver
effectivement à cette victoire
électorale de novembre dernier
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'en mars 2020
madame aung san suu kyi et la lnd avait
proposé au parlement des amendements à
la constitution pour que le contrôle des
militaires sur la constitution et sur la
politique du pays cessent ces
propositions avaient été évidemment
refusé mais il était évident que
aujourd'hui avec une légitimité accrue
l'icône de la démocratie serait revenue
sur le devant de la scène avec ce
dossier excessivement sensible pour les
intérêts à long terme des militaires des
militaires qui ne sont pas soutenus par
la population bien mal écouté très peu
de militaires très peu de birmans
soutiennent la population vous savez il
ya quand même eu plus de cinq décennies
je dirais d'oppression et donc
aujourd'hui les militaires ne sont pas
associés à un moment de paix d'autant
plus que depuis l'indépendance
la birmanie est confronté à une
multitude de conflits ethniques plus ou
moins importants et que finalement on se
rend compte avec un peu de distance que
les militaires actives tel ou tel
conflit qu pour justifier leur maintien
sur le devant de la scène politique et
sécuritaire et donc si vous voulez il y
a aussi une espèce de
sentiment qu'ils s'expriment alors il
s'exprime pas directement parce que les
birmans ne ont peur effectivement et ne
veulent pas être dénoncés mais dès qu'on
est dans une situation d'anonymat
respecté à ce moment là ils vous disent
que vraiment les militaires ont fait
beaucoup de mal à leur pays et d'un tout
dernier mot plus de 10 ans après le
retour au downtown sushi est ce que
c'est une page qui se tourne en birmanie
ce qu on peut même parler d'un retour en
arrière
écoutez on va voir la suite des
événements ce qui est sûr c'est que si
le programme des militaires se met
véritablement en place c'est à dire si
pendant un an il y à un état d'urgence
et puis qui lie à d'éventuelles
élections qui seront très certainement
noyautée par par l'armée oui on peut
parler d'une régression et même d'une
régression majeure est évidemment très
dommageable pour la transition dans ce
pays
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse sophie
boisseau du rocher chercheuse associée
au sont razi de l'institut de l'institut
français des relations internationales